bonjour chers internautes pour ce
nouveau numéro de diagonale la leçon
aujourd'hui un tour de force
notre ami et loire l'ange va vous nous
expliquer les échecs en 10 questions
réponses
alors c'est moi qui vais poser les
questions c'est toi qui va faire les
réponses c'est simple la première
question c'est quel est le but d'une ou
plutôt comment se déroule une partie
d'échecs
oui alors une partie d'échec c'est une
partie entre deux joueurs déjà il faut
deux joueurs un plateau de jeu en
échiquier avec toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier donc là c'est ce l'écran que
vous voyez tout de suite ici dans le
fond cet écran avec donc cette pièce de
chaque couleur et ça va être
chacun son tour de jouer un coup donc il
ya un joueur qui joue les blancs un
joueur qui joue les qui joue les noirs
un jour les blancs les noirs chaque
pièce a sa spécificité la tour se
déplacent verticale et colonnes le fou
en diagonale la dame fait une tour plus
un fou c'est à dire et les diagonales et
les colonnes le pion avance d'une case
ou deux cases on y reviendra et
lecavalier il fait 1 l
donc en fait chaque pièce à sa
spécification et c'est chacun son tour
de jouer un coup alors on va faire une
petite partie on va voir une petite
partie quelques premiers coups alors les
les blanches où les blancs jouent donc
là le pion a le droit d'avoir ses deux
cases devant lui puisque c'est le
premier kouamé comme on écoute pions les
noirs répondent à coeur chacun son tour
de jouer chacun son tour on ne peut pas
passer
on ne peut pas passer aux échecs on est
obligé d'y jouer
imposer d un coût de 4 e 5 donc ça c'est
les coordonnées du jeu d'échecs mais ça
c'est pas ça nous regarde pas puisque la
partie se déroule donc entre deux
joueurs chacun son tour joué un coup ou
ici c'est de nouveau band jouer puisque
les noirs a répondu cette fois ci
peuvent rejouer des pions ils peuvent
jouer n'importe quelle pièce n'importe
où du moment que c'est un coup légal
c'est-à-dire là en l'occurrence ils ont
déplacé leurs cavaliers donc en elle
le cavalier en est d'accord ici les
noirs maintenant c'est à eux de jouer
d'accord sont
ils sont là ils ont encore le choix
toujours tous les coups sont permis
cavalli c6 donc c'est un exemple
toujours un fou avance on continue
chacun joue sceptiques où on met ces
pièces en jeu en face on l'a pour
l'instant on ne cherche pas à expliquer
et le dernier coup le dernier quart
d'heure c'est l'année coûte 7 voilà le
dernier coup de cette partie donc ici
c'est un exemple il y a deux joueurs
chacun de chacun des plats sans ses
propre armée c'est une armée c'est là
par rapport au jeu de dames c'est que la
seule différence est que finalement il
ya des pièces qui bouge différemment
weeds how we may alors aux dames
effectivement il ya des pions et des
dames mais ici tout les cas il y a dès
le début toutes les pièces sont
différentes les vagues lecavalier chacun
qui s'est chaque cas sa propre
spécificité et donc il ya des cases
forte
il ya des endroits force sur l'échiquier
à prendre il ya tout des stratégies qui
se met en place mais la base du jeu
d'échecs le déroulement de la partie
c'est chacun joue à son tour d'accord
ben ça me semble clair c'est que
maintenant il ya un camp blanc un camp
noir si qui commence c'est toujours le
joueur qui a les blancs qui commence la
partie d'échecs voilà donc les blancs
jouent et gagnent 0 vous fait ou c'est
faux ça dépend du point de vue la
précédente place la merci des lois
deuxième question une deuxième question
quel est le but qu'est ce qu'on cherche
à faire quand on joue aux échecs alors
aux échecs le but ultime de la partie
d'échec c'est de gagner
alors gagner ça se passe par l'échec et
mat
le fameux échec et mat donc
effectivement ça va la partie va se
dérouler chacun rejoint son tour des
coups et au bout d'un certain moment il
va y avoir possibilité d'échec et mat
qu'est ce que c'est un échec et mat
alors vraiment en train de nous ici par
exemple la dame vient de se déplacer là
elle s'est mise face au roi noir donc l
attaque le roi noir
d'accord il est et ce roi ne peut plus
en fuyant puisque toutes les cases sont
contrôlés par la dame donc ça c'est un
exemple la dame contrôlons ces cinq
cases ça c'est un échec et mat mais là
le roi peut pas prendre la dame blanche
là le roi ne peut pas prendre la dame
blanche puisqu'il se mettrait alors en
échec
c'est à dire que la dame blanche est
défendue par le roi blanc donc là
simplement le roi noir naples et de gaz
c'est un exemple simple des chats
keynote donc échec les badges
je récapitule c'est faire échec c'est à
dire attaqué le roi et il a plus de
possibilité de s'en sortir et ça c'est
ce qu'on cherche à faire alors là tu
nous a montré une position dépouillé 1
par rapport à celle de tout à l'heure
comment on arrive à ça alors hein parce
que c'est pas si simple
effectivement au début de chaque joueur
à cette pièce donc ça va passer par une
diminution du matériel adverse
la partie va se dérouler il va y avoir
des échanges
elle est prise donc en fait un moyen
d'arriver à cet échec et mat le moyen le
plus simple est reconnu par par tous du
débutant au grand maître
ouais c'est de gagner du matériel ils se
mangeaient c'est ce que disent les
enfants dans les écoles ils disent on
mange on à chevaux manger il faut manger
donc là c'est un exemple très simple une
fois plus épuré c'est aux blancs de
jouer et il joue tour contours gagneront
une tour d' accor est là puisque les
noirs n'ont pas possibilité de reprendre
cette tour c'est les règles du jeu ici
tout reprend tout à gagner une tour dont
il a gagné du matériel et avec troyes et
tours on va finir par mater d'accord
très bien donc
le but du jeu léché avec ses de mater
mais pour y arriver aux maths on essaye
de piquer de manger il alors on essaie
de manger les pièces adverse et ça
commence comme un combat de rue dès les
premiers coups de la partie il va y
avoir des prises des attaques des
menaces chacun son tour de jouer celui
qui aura pris le plus de matériel aura
le plus de chance de mater à la fin de
la partie
très bien alors il me vient à l'esprit
est une autre question
c'est alors évidemment comment peuvent
se terminer les parties d'échecs s'est
toujours matt ou c ou s'il ya d'autres
possibilités
non alors il ya effectivement d'autres
possibilités la partie d'échecs
effectivement il ya une possibilité
simple un joueur gagne alors ça c'est
soit échec et mat soit chez nous ce
qu'on vient de voir ce qu'on vient de
voir
soit un joueur estime qu' il a perdu
qu'il va perdre qui n'a plus aucune
chance de s'en sortir
et dans ce cas il abandonne même il ya
une sorte de frustration par exemple
quand on voit les parties entre
champions dans les journaux on voit ben
dont on joue la partie et on comprend
pas toujours pourquoi il abandonne
oui alors il ya différents niveaux de
compréhension bien entendu quand un
grand maître abandonne contre un autre
grand maître c'est on ne comprend pas
tout de suite pourquoi simplement avec
l'expérience avec l'accroissement du
niveau de jeu on comprend très bien que
mathématiquement il n'y a plus de
chances de s'en sortir mais ça ça fait
abandon alors effectivement dans les
partis
batteur et de débutants l'abandon est
extrêmement rare j'irai jusqu'au matin
je comprends pourquoi on perd impasse
quant aux il ya toujours des
possibilités de s'en sortir au fond et
toi ton conseil s'est pas d'avoir donné
tout de suite alors ça c'est dépenser
davantage de l'abandon ça ça a le mérite
d'éviter le ridicule puisque de temps en
temps effectivement la position n'a plus
aucune chance aucun espoir donc là ça ne
sert vraiment à rien de continuer ça
serait plus un manque de respect pour
l'adversaire plutôt qu'autre chose donc
ça c'est les deux possibilités de gagner
le parti soit en maths notre adversaire
soit ils abandonnent d'accord ça c'est
en gagne alors est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
possibilités
oui aux échecs il ya une troisième
possibilité soit on gagne soit on perd
mais il ya aussi la partie nulle la
partie nul donc chaque joueur prônons la
moitié du pont alors comment comment on
fait comme on fait nul pour arriver à la
nulle il ya trois possibilités la
première étant celle que je vais vous
montrer ici vous voyez le diagramme
c'est la répétition de coups un
pétillant de coûts allant ici les blancs
ont sont dominés ils ont ils sont
écrasés au point de vue matériel puisque
les noirs ont deux tours de plus vous
voyez ici deux tours on habitait fuite
tour c'est combien ça vaut comme ça vaut
10 points 10 points les deux toits valdi
pas donc là c'est énorme c'est énorme
les noirs vont gagner cette partie sauf
que et blanc jouent dame f6 échec au roi
c'est un échec c'est un échec qui ne
peut pas être pareil donc le roi doit
s'en aller pour enfin pour éviter cet
échec
roger vite hélas les blancs reviennent
sur la case du g5
alors une fois de plus et chaque oran et
le roi doit repartir sur la seule place
disponible ici la case à schwyz et là on
revient encore sur cette case f6 on
renouvelle l'échec au roi les noirs
n'ont toujours pas d'autre choix que de
revenir en j'ai vite d'accord et on
recommence c'est une sorte de chasse à
l'homme mais je dirais que c'est une
sorte de renvoi de balle
sauf qu'on est obligé de renvoyer la
balle à son adversaire en partant de là
il arrive à faire échec mais il arrive
pas faire échec et mat au fond il
n'arrive pas à la cheville nahd et il
sait très bien que s'ils arrêtent cette
série d'échecs
donc on revoit rouages suite d'ahmed 6
d'accord c'est la troisième fois qu'on a
cette position là il n'a pas arrêté
cette série d'échecs la partie et donc
déclarer nul l'accord c'est l'échec
perpétuelle c'est l'échec perpétuelle
est une vulgarisation en fait est un
un sous-ensemble sous un seul à
répétition mais titien puisqu'on peut
aussi imaginer des répétitions qui
serait par exemple si chacun change
c'est chacun si un joueur des vies il va
perdre la partie
mais comme une sorte de balance qui se
fait que l'on répète la présidence a
peut être la position ça c'est une fois
ci une possibilité d'une une possibilité
nul alors voyons une autre possibilité
de nul c'est tout simplement le path
alors ça ce n'est pas m'as tu sais pas
tu position très simple très épuré les
blancs au roi et dames les noirs n'ont
plus qu'un roi 1 que les blancs vont
gagner c'est sûr fier que ici c'est au
noir de jouer et alors là qu'est ce
qu'on remarque est bien la dame blanche
contrôler toutes les 15 autour du roi
noir et comme aux échecs effectivement
on ne peut pas dire je passe n'a qu on
ne peut pas jouer c'est à dire quand on
n'a plus le droit quand on a plus de
coûts légaux a été réussi un coup légal
c'est un coût qui n'est pas le roi
emprise d'accord là il faudra si les
noirs devaient échouer un coup parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre pour les
jeunes les jeunes amateurs qui peuvent
nous il pourrait neiger leroy côté
nantais peuvent pas parce qu'ils n'ont
pas droit de se mettre en échec son pas
le droit se mettre en échec donc ici
c'est un exemple typique où les noirs
dont ne peuvent pas jouer le coup ouais
ils sont donc pattes c'est différent du
mat pas laisser les banques ont en effet
un échec
ça fait une grosse différence puisque
mate on a perdu la partie alors que
quand on est pat c'est une partie nulle
donc ça veut dire que dans cette
position les blancs à un moment donné de
la partie au match joué puisqu'il avait
quand même une dame d'avancé
complètement idiot de faire pas donc
faire part parties nulles oui on peut
dire oui effectivement là les blancs
vont très mal joué c'est une gaffe de
fin de partie comme quoi n'abandonnez
pas même même avec lorient sur
l'échiquier on peut toujours s'en sortir
avec le pat d'accord nul on peut faire
répétition de cauet cheikh perpétuelle
on va d accès sont des cousins pâte est
alors l'accord négocié une autre
possibilité
c'est 50 coups sans prise et 100
sans prise dès son coup de pied est ce
un coup de pub alors ça c'est une règle
une règle internationale d'accord quand
on quand on voit une position où les
chacun des joueurs a joué 50 trousses et
les blancs jouent à 50 ou et noir ont
joué cinquante aussi et qu'il n'y a pas
eu de coups de pions et pas de prise on
considère que la position n'évolue plus
on dit que la partie il la partie de
déclarer nous c'est un peu comme la
moulinette judo on n'y a pas assez de
compatibilité je connais je ne suis pas
juge obtient effectivement la partie est
déclarée nulle par manque de manque
d'action tout simplement et alors il me
semble moi j'ai déjà vu aussi dans mes
rubrique clips et le figaro qui ont
dérobé des chèques parfois on voit nulle
part convention mutuelle voilà c'est la
dernière possibilité pour faire nul tout
comme l'abandon
les joueurs peuvent se mettre d'accord
non pas pour qu'un abandon mais pour
faire partie nulle c'est à dire ils
estiment tous les deux que leurs
positions ne va plus évolué ou
simplement qui par respect mutuel dans
une position équilibrée on s'accorde là
nul et donc c'est la quatrième cas nulle
part convention mutuelle bon alors il ya
quand même beaucoup de possibilités de
gagner ou de faire nul voilà les
terminaisons de l'avant les blés les
plus simples c'est quand même l'abandon
le mat et d'échecs perpétuelle
quand même je sais que perpétuelle est
assez fréquent on est assez fréquent bon
alors une autre question
une règle très importante que tout le
monde connaît un petit peu mais que tout
le monde ne maîtrise pas bien c'est le
rock comme quand peut-on rockets
pourquoi peut-on ranquet à quoi ça sert
comment ça se passe alors le rock voilà
le rox et c'est le roi c'est un
mouvement du roi et de la tour
c'est l'un des seuls mouvements double
aux échecs le seul le sol
c'est celui qui va donc déplacé deux
pièces simultanément puisque un coup aux
échecs normalement c'est une pièce qui
bouge ou alors une pièce qui prend une
autre pièce d'accord le rock c'est
différent c'est qu'on prend notre roi on
l'amène on le déplace de deux cas soit à
gauche ou à droite n'a qu'un pass la
tour par dessus d'accord donc ça c'est
l'europe dont vous avez fréquemment
entendu parler donc un petit exemple
dans cette position on voit que la
première rangée des blancs est
totalement dégagée c'est qu'il n'ya plus
que le roi et la tour mais tais toi qui
revient entre le roi et les tours où la
tour voilà est ici donc qu'est ce qui va
se passer donc elle le petit rock
qu'on va montrer ici alors si on rails
se trouvent certaines positions
fantastique
oui les noirs et les blancs couverts que
les noirs et les blancs avaient la
possibilité de rock est donc ici huit
petit rock que les noirs peuvent faire
le petit rock mais ils peuvent également
faire ce qu'on appelle le grand roque
d'accord alors pourquoi petits et grands
parce que le petit rock
il est du côté où il n'y a que deux
cases entre le roi et le joker le grand
côté où il ya trois cases d'accord et
voilà le grand roque un exemple de grand
roque ici mais alors maintenant à quoi
ça sert de rock et puisque pratiquement
dans parmi les joies de compétition il
rock à 95%
oui le rox et c'est très très fort
pourquoi parce que ça mais le roi
dernière les pions en général ont avancé
seulement les pions du centre donc ça va
faire une protection naturelle pour le
roi et en même temps ça va amener la
tour vers le centre c'est donc un coût
très important
ah c'est un coup à double effet qui est
qui et percutant puisque ça protège en
même temps le roi et en même temps ces
actifs la tour ça la met en jeu voilà le
rock
alors évidemment aux échecs mais si au
final il ya peu de règles qui sont
compliqués c'est
maintenant on sait quand on peu rauque
et caen ne peut-on par ok effectivement
il ya des cas on ne peut pas invoquer ce
que nous allons voir ici un premier
exemple exemple épuré une fois de plus
là on va dire donc c'est aux blancs de
jouer ils peuvent a priori rock et
puisque le roi la tour
enfin le roi et les deux tours sont
encore sur les cases d'origine
d'accord mais il ya une impossibilité
c'est à dire qu'on peut essayer de rock
est dans cette position le coup et
refusés par l'ordinateur on profuse est
en fait avoir par les règles du jeu
parce que le roi blanc est actuellement
mise en échec par un fonds alors on ne
peut pas rock et quand ton est en échec
oui on ne peut pas re ok quand on est en
échec par contre ouais donc là ça va
être notre prochain exemple corps non ce
n'est pas notre prochaine alors s'il
passe peut-être l'exemple voilà alors
une autre possibilité une hotte
impossibilité de rock on va revenir là
dessus parce que je crois que c'est très
important ici les blancs ne sont pas en
échec
il n'y a rien entre le roi et les tours
et contre le petit rock et quand même
impossible donc on va essayer le petit
rock ça ne marche toujours décidément
cette machine est terrible cette machine
est terrible qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est l'effet de ce fou en a six
d'accord qui contrôle cette case là
ouais la case à côté du roi
donc en fait on n'a pas le droit de rock
et quand les cases proches du roi sont
sont attaqués par des pièces et nîmes
parce que finalement dans l'esprit de la
règle on considère que le roi passe par
sept cas c'est ça que ça veut dire oui
mais effectivement si une des trois
cases en fait pour généraliser cette
règle si le détroit 4 verte ici sont
contrôlés le petit rock sera impossible
pourquoi si cette case là y contrôler le
roi est en échec un échec si cette case
là laquelle j'ai contrôlé le roi serait
en échec en quatre petits rock ouais ce
qui est donc une impossibilité de jeu et
si cette case est contrôlé il
considérait lui être en échec
il aurait pu être en échec il est passé
par une case où il était en échec mec
donc c'est impossible donc ça s'appelle
je crois l'expression s'est passé sous 1
avec passer sous un échec donc
expression qui veut bien dire ce qu'elle
veut dire en revanche pour la tour ça
n'est pas un problème puisque là les
blancs peuvent jouer le grand roque sans
aucun souci donc ce qui est important ce
sont les cases par lesquels le roi passe
un leak aspérités le droit passe et non
pas celle par laquelle la tour tapas
d'accord alors premier on n'a pas le
rock et quand on est en échec qu'on n'a
pas droit de passer sous un échec
troisième impossibilité on ne peut pas
re ok quand le roi a bougé le roi ou la
tour ont bougé voilà ici exemple très
simple les nuls en avoir enfin le roi
blanc était en effet il revient en vain
les noirs déplacent leurs cavaliers et
en la maintenant j'ai droit de rock et
puisque j'ai sujet la position de départ
à priori oui oui en fait non simplement
puisque c'est la règle
une fois que le roi a bougé le mois où
la tour ont bougé oui
impossibilité de rock est d'accord alors
bien entendu si dans cette position
c'est seulement sept tours là qu'ils
allaient bouger et que le roi est là
tout est donc du côté petit roth n'avait
pas bougé le petit rock serait possible
accord par contre en revanche dès que le
roi bouger plus de rock que lundi qu'une
tour à bouger plus de rock deux côtés de
cette fois je crois qu'il faut se
rassurer puisque ça arrive même aux plus
grands champions je crois que j'ai assez
à karpov que c'est arrivé en partie
rapide le stress il avait bougé son roi
il est revenu à la case de départ il
s'est passé trente coups il est en
partie rapide et puis la rocqué et son
adversaire en face qui était un grand m
mais finalement ça arriverait un canon
ne vous inquiétez pas ça n'arrive pas
tous les matins
même les plus grands peuvent oublier ses
règles mais enfin il faut quand même les
connaître parce que ça
évidemment ça conditionne une bonne
partie d'échecs et le dernier cas le
dernier cas voilà c'est ça on a vu qu'on
ne pouvait par ok quand on était en
échec
oui ici le roi blanc est en échec donc
on parle échec par les chefs en
interposant une pièce de van acker vous
voyez le fou maintenant 3 va te reposer
entre lavaur et droit mettons que les
noirs jouent un coup comme tour e7 est
ici a lâché moindre ad-rock et puisque
j'étais en échec
et bien non puisque le roi a été en
échec mais n'a pas bougé quand il n'est
plus en échec et récupère dont son
endroit brooke est donc ici possibles
soit le grand roque à 42 15 tours
passent par dessus soit le petit rock
d'accord là on adore je crois que c'est
important de rhodia parce qu'il ya
parfois certains novices qui confondent
1 on est en échec
on n'a pas le droit de rock et pendant
qu'on est en échec mais quand on a été
une fois en échec qu'on apparaît l'échec
on à droite qu'on de continuer à roque
et un le petit rock et le grand roque
je pense qu'on les a bien ciblé est ici
effectivement toutes les impossibilités
de rock ont été un père taulier donc
dernière question fort ok ou faux par ok
rapidement oui alors évidemment le rock
il faut le faire il faut le faire
toujours ok pour les raisons qu'on a
mentionné s'amèneront à l'abri ça mais
là tout en jeu
le rock est un bon élément alors une
autre question qu'on se pose c'est à
propos des petits pions qui est dans
fielder disait qu'ils étaient l'âme du
jeu d'échecs alors est ce que moi je
vais poser une question idiote est ce
qu'on a le droit d'avoir quatre dames ou
trois cavaliers aux échecs
alors là ça fait appel évidemment à la
promotion
alors pourquoi puisque au début on a que
deux cavaliers a priori à la fin de la
partie on en aura pas trois puisque les
pièces ont plutôt tendance à disparaître
qu'apparaître mais il existe une règle
aux échecs qui fait que quand un pion
arrive tout en haut de l'échiquier
arrive donc sur la première rangée du
camp ennemi il ya le droit de se
transformer en n'importe quelle pièce
c'est la règle de la promotion et là on
va voir que cette règle n'a aucune
limite dans n'importe quelle pièce c'est
à dire qu'on peut avoir deux dames on
peut avoir trois cavaliers c'est ce qui
était en train de nous dire c'est
important parce que souvent les gens se
disent on a le droit de prendre que les
pièces qu'on ait déjà été prise
oui eh bien non et bien annoncer si vous
avez un échiquier chez vous avec donc 32
pièces qu'il faut faire un troisième
cavaliers bien vous ne pourrez pas le
faire physiquement puisque votre boîte
ne vous le permettra pas par contre
virtuellement on peut faire promotion
cavaliers on peut prendre un simili un
simili de cavaliers ouais et est donc
jouer avec trois cavaliers vaut mieux
acheter plusieurs jeux d'échecs saison
les deux jeux d'échecs vous serez
tranquille à la toutes les promotions
seront sont donc ici exemple très simple
car l'option est arrivé là le point noir
est arrivé il est proche de la première
rangée et demi et il joue le coup puis
on prend j'ai un cavalier qui fait un
échec
un donc position si on avait fait dame
ça aurait été moins bien puisque le roi
n'aura pas été en échec d'accord d'un
piège théorique connu ici dans cette
position-là du contrebandier albin il
faut jouer pions pranger un échec
un promotion cavaliers très important et
c'est comme ça que les noirs gagne
d'accord wasquehal a donc là l'intérêt
c'est d'avoir trois cavaliers - même si
les prix rapidement peu importe parce
qu'on fait échec assez souvent
lula bon on prend la dame à la plupart
du temps quand même on prend la dame
notamment dans 80% des cas avec en
censurant la dame on prend parfois le
cavalier parce qu'on peut faire échec à
donc ça permet de gagner un temps c'est
ça oui et fouet tour c'est pour éviter
le pad c'est ça voilà fou et où on les
prend parce que justement il contrôle
moins de 15 que la dame c'est des pièces
fortes quand même
et quand on veut pas faire dame parce
que promotion dame entraînerait un pacte
entre
trop de casse eh bien on fait une tour
ou un fou qui évite qu'ils évitent ce
drame puisque pâte rappelons que c'est
nul
alors que avec une tour ou un fou plus
on va gagner la partie
donc je repose ma question est ce qu'on
peut avoir dix cavaliers dix cavaliers
la réponse est oui tout accueillant 2 +
8 pions qui vont à promotion voilà c'est
possible alors une autre question est ce
que en début de partie je peux avancer
mes pions deux pions d'une case
je joue au premier coup je joue au
premier coup de la partie est ce que
j'ai le droit d'avancer de pions d'une
case 1 ça aurait gelé vue je l' ai vu
faire souvent quand même oui alors
d'option d'une carte on l'a vu faire
souvent mais ce n'est pas une ce départ
poule légal on n'a pas le droit
par contre on a droit d'avancer un pion
de deux cases mais d'option d'une case
ça n'existe pas effectivement je les ai
vus également mais c'est une règle qui
n'a jamais existé depuis
alors est-ce qu'on a droit d'avancé donc
on a droit d'avancer le pion de deux
cases mais pendant toute la partie
oui oui alors l'option de deux cases
effectivement le coup le plus connu aux
échecs ce2 cartes qu'on verra tout de
suite après cet exemple on a le droit
d'avancer dès le premier coup la partie
au deuxième coup aussi et même quand on
arrive dans une pression de fin de
partie comme celle qui est ici c'est
encore possible puisque là donc les
blancs n'ont plus qu'un pion mais il a
le droit d'avancer de deux cases c'est
ce qu'on voit ici il joue un bep deux
des quatre échecs et mat
n'as tu pas ce que le pion attaque le
roi noir il est défendu par le roi blanc
et donc on va voir on va mentionner
toutes les possibilités pour sortir le
renoir ne pas manger une de ses propres
pièces c'est en montant
c'était loin de questions est oui et
donc on voit que toutes les cases en
fait les cases de renoir sont occupés
puisque le roi blanc ici contrôle et une
vie à une autre question c'est à dire
que tout les mêmes un petit pion peut
attaquer un roi un fou peut attaquer une
dame un cavalier une tour c'est
il n'y a pas de problème
disons que oui oui alors je ne peux pas
répondre à ta question c'est totalement
vrai je vais te poser une autre question
sur ses ondes improvise d'un seul coup
même si elle me vient tout de suite
c'est la valeur des pièces souvent
souvent quand on débute on aime les
cavaliers et on pense que le cavalier
c'est la plus forte des pièces oui alors
il planqué derrière valeur des pièces on
pense que le cavalier plus fort qu'une
dame par exemple puisque il est plus
surprenant
ça c'est mon analyse je dirais
sociologique mais alors les pièces sont
une valeur les pièces sont une valeur
on va donner comme valeurs de base le
pion en tuant vos seins 1.1 point
le cavalier vaut trois points d'accord
le fou à peu près pareil qu'un cavalier
c'est à dire trois points d'accord la
tour est plus forte puisqu'elle va très
vite très loin de la tour est plus forte
que le full cavaliers que le full
cavaliers wintour vos cinq points
d'accord donc si on peut faire un petit
bilan tout de suite une tour est un pion
savoie peu près pareil qu'un four et un
cavalier puisque c'est la clé six points
pour chacun et la pièce la plus forte
c'est la dame puisqu'elle vaut 10 points
et le roi ça vaut combien alors le roi
ça n'a pas de prix
suite à la vague le roi n'est pas une
pièce forte se déplace pas loin pas vite
mais mais le roi si on ne peut pas le
perdre puisque sinon on a perdu la
partie
bon on passe est une autre question
une dernière question pour aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que quelle est la différence
et quelle est la pièce la plus forte
la dame où le roi alors ça effectivement
c'est une question qu'on entend souvent
il y en a beaucoup qui demande ça est ce
que vous préférez le roi ou la dame
et bien c'est un peu comme le président
et le premier ministre c'est à dire que
le président est là s'est il se pose là
c'est le cndd hommes qui dirigent le
gouvernant qui dirige l'état en fait
c'est le garant de l'état par contre le
premier ministre prend les décisions
alors là c'est un peu pareil
le roi c'est le garant de l'armée tant
que le roi est vivant on continue à
jouer
par contre il n'est pas très efficaces
ils avancent que d'une case à la fois en
revanche la dame elle va très loin très
vite c'est une pièce très forte mais on
peut sacrifier la dame on peut perdre la
dame et la partie continue donc
la dame est plus forte mais le rôle plus
important la dame est plus forte et le
roi le plus important c'est le mot de la
fin chers internautes j'espère que on
vous reverra pour un autre questions
réponses avec le grand maître et loire
lange
merci bertrand est allé très vite
oh